i think most of us have a sense that
payday loans are probably not the best
source for a loan that they probably
charge a lot of money to those people
who need that cash really badly and what
i want to do in this video is one
explain what they are but even more do a
little bit of math to understand really
how bad
of an interest that they do charge so
the way that it works is let's say that
you know i i need to buy my wife a nice
gift for her birthday that's tomorrow
and i want to borrow 500
so i want to borrow
500
i would suspect that most people aren't
borrowing it for some type of a gift
they're desperate to make the rent or uh
pay the utilities or or buy food or who
knows what else but whatever your reason
you need to borrow 500 and
i would suspect that you have very
little in your bank account otherwise
you wouldn't go to the payday lender and
they say all right sal we're open to
lending you 500 we're not going to do
all of this deep uh uh research on on
how good of a credit you are and all of
that but we want a couple of things one
we want to know your pay stub and your
pay date so let me suppose they want
your
they're going to want to see your pay
stub
pay stub they're going to they want to
know when you're going to get paid so
your pay
i guess we could call it your payday
your payday and they might want some
recent bank statements some recent bank
statements
and the whole reason why they want these
things is
is they want to know you know even
though your credit might be horrible
that you're going to get a you're going
to get a a
your salary or you're going to get a
payment from your employer probably in
two weeks on your payday
and then you're going to be good to pay
back the 500
and to ensure this so one they're going
to make sure that you have a job that
you
and you're pay stub maybe you make a
a thousand dollars every two weeks or
maybe you make two thousand dollars
every two weeks so that you're good for
this so maybe it's you know maybe you
make fifteen hundred dollars
every two weeks so they like to see that
maybe your payday is two weeks from the
day that you're borrowing it
borrowing the money so two weeks
two weeks
from
today
and then your bank statement shows that
your bank kind of goes up fifteen
hundred dollars and you pay the rent and
the food then it goes back close to zero
then it goes up to fifteen hundred
dollars but they wanna see that this
fifteen hundred dollars is hitting
periodically and they say you know what
we're gonna do we're gonna give you the
five hundred dollars today what we wanna
do is
you need to write us a check and on that
check let me let me draw a check right
here
so this is a check that they want you to
write
we want you to write a check for not 500
for every 100 you borrow so for
every
hundred dollars borrowed
borrowed
you want i want you to pay us back
another twenty five dollars
so twenty five dollars
extra and at first you might say hey
that's not bad that's 25 interest it's
high maybe it compares to some interest
to some credit cards but this isn't 25 a
year this is 25
for two weeks and at the end of this
video we're gonna do a little bit of
math on what that actually turns into on
an apr or an effective apr basis and
these numbers are not crazy these are
actually very typical for payday loans
so if i'm borrowing 500
i have to give them back the 500 in two
weeks plus twenty five dollars for every
hundred dollars so i'm borrowing five
hundred dollars i'm gonna have to do
plus five times 25 or
or 125 dollars so i'm going to write
them a check
for 500 plus 125 so that's 625
625
dollars right there i'm going to write a
check but obviously i don't have the
money in my bank account right now
otherwise i wouldn't even be going to
the payday loan but what i'm doing the
date i'm going to forward date this
check i'm going to put the date let's
say this is the first of the month
instead of let's say it's january 1st
instead of january 1st i'm going to put
1
16 and you know whatever
year i might be doing it so i'm
forwarded this is two weeks from today
two weeks
in
the
future and then you know i'm gonna sign
i'm gonna sign the check
and well maybe usually you sign you know
sign the check and i'll write it for
payday
payday loan and i'll write 6 i'll write
600. i'll write out the words
600 and exit 25 et cetera et cetera and
then i have my little information here
and i'm going to give them this check
and what they're going to say is we're
not going to cache this we're just going
to keep this nice little check for us
and when your payday hits you have an
option you can come back to us and give
us 625
625 dollars in cash and then we will
give you back this check that is
uncached or if you don't show up we are
just going to cash this check so one of
these two things are going to happen but
effectively they're going to if this if
you didn't lie to them they're going to
essentially charge you 625 and you can
imagine it is risky for the lender
because these are people with
you know maybe shady pay stubs and
obviously they're desperate so they
weren't good at managing their finances
but they're doing their best to ensure
that once that payday comes in once that
that that payment from the employer
comes in that they get first dibs on the
money before the person can pay their
rent or their utilities or their food
and so that's the general idea behind it
now we started off saying that it's
probably not a good idea and you got a
sense of that because we're essentially
paying 25 interest for every two weeks
not for every year but let's think about
what that is on an apr basis
so let's say we're paying so 25 for
every 100 that's really 25 percent when
you say per
cent
cent that root means 100 right century
100 years so per cent it literally means
per 100 25 per 100 so this is literally
25
interest or we could write it in the
traditional way this is 25
interest
interest
per two weeks
per two weeks so if we were to just
calculate a simple apr a simple annual
percentage interest rate
annual
percentage rate
percentage rate
and you might want to watch the video on
that to understand that that just takes
your 25 percent your 25 percent and then
multiplies by the number of periods in
the year so we have 52 weeks per year
but this is every two weeks so instead
of multiplying it by 52 weeks we're
going to multiply it by there's 26 two
week periods in the year so times 26
two week
periods
periods
per
year
and this is 25
per
per two weeks and when you multiply this
out
this is equal to let's get the
calculator out
so you have i'll just multiply the
numbers i won't do as a decimal 20 let
me turn it on 25
times 26 times 26 is equal to
650 percent
we're paying an apr of 600 650
so if you thought the credit card
companies were charging a lot of
interest charging you a i don't know a
mid-teens interest rate or 20 interest
rate this is
650 it's a it's a an order of magnitude
or two above what even credit cards
charge you so this is a really really
crazy annual percentage rate and this
was just a simple annual percentage rate
where we multiplied it by 26. this isn't
the effective annual percentage rate or
the actual mathematically correct one to
do that we would actually have to take
and you might want to watch the video on
this if you were to let that just
compound and you could imagine if you're
the payday lender you are essentially
getting that compounding if you keep
lending your money out and if you lend
the interest you get from the last
person you lend that out at the same
rate to figure out that effective annual
percent rate you do 1.25
right 25 percent plus 1
to the 26th power we have 26 of these
periods in a year and what is that going
to be equal to
so we have
1.25
to the 26th power
and then we get
this crazy number we're going to want to
subtract a 1 from it not that it's going
to change much of our math so minus 1
and we get
320
well let me be very clear we're gonna
we're going to be essentially this is
300 this is 329 times our money so if
this was a 1 here that would be 100
so this is let me just be clear this
number right here
that number right there
it's such a high number it's hard to
fathom if you were to actually let money
compound at this rate and usually they
wouldn't let you just they make you at
least roll over the principle so this
may or may not be accurate but the
actual payday lender if the money if
they actually do are able to roll over
the money at this rate they're going to
have 329
times their money if you write it as a
percent it would literally be
three let me make sure i get the three
two nine eight seven literally thirty
two thousand nine hundred and eighty
seven percent or after a year you'll
essentially have to pay roughly 330
times your money back to the to the
payday lender and obviously they don't
let you compound like that but this just
gives you a sense of how ridiculous this
interest rate is i mean you might have
heard of the term usury
usury in the past usury really meant any
kind of interest but now in our current
cultural context we associate it with
just an unreasonable level of interest
and that threshold might be different
for some people some people might say
it's unreasonable to pay twenty percent
interest or thirty percent interest or
forty percent annual interest but i
think everyone would agree that whether
you look at six hundred fifty percent or
thirty three thousand percent these are
users and unreasonable interest rates so
you really at all costs unless it's you
know you your life depends on it you
want to avoid these payday loans